everyone in this photo died soon after
it was taken these are British explorers
standing at the South Pole in January
1912 the photo marks the finish line of
a race into the unknown two teams one
British one Norwegian trekked 900 miles
into brutal territory and had to get
back to safety before winter hit and at
first glance this looks like a victory
photo for the British except that is the
Norwegian flag and it only gets worse
from here Robert Falcon Scott was a
meticulous planner and his dream was to
be the first person to reach the South
Pole he and his English team of
explorers and scientists had been
conducting research in Antarctica and
collected years of data on seasonal
cycles on the continent these lines show
what the estimated average temperatures
would be throughout the year
with summer ranging from around 30 to
negative 10 degrees Fahrenheit and huge
drops beginning around April remember
this chart because later it will help us
understand Scott's decision-making scott
planned to use pony transport for the
first 425 miles across the Ross Ice
Shelf shoot them at the base of the
Beardmore glacier and finish the rest of
the journey on foot which included a 125
mile hike across the top of the glacier
350 more miles to the pole and all the
way back again
all while hauling hundreds of pounds of
equipment using ponies and brute
strength made sense to Scott at the time
British explorers had used this method
to haul equipment during an earlier
attempt on the South Pole plus the
English Dannette experience with the
other good option dog teams and they
believed man hauling was the surest way
to make the tricky climb of the glacier
and onto the polar plateau where the
South Pole sits it was hard to slow work
but the route they were on had reached a
plateau before and it seemed to be worth
the effort but Scott's team wasn't alone
Norwegian explorer Roald Amundsen was
camped nearby and he wanted to get to
the pole first the Norwegian team all of
them expert skiers knew how to travel in
cold conditions and to make matters
worse for the English Amundsen had dogs
and he knew how to use them
news of the Norwegians last-minute bid
worried Scott but he was still
optimistic Amundsen had started about
sixty miles closer to the pole but was
taking a route not yet proven to be
passable coming against an unknown
obstacle or falling into an unmarked
crevasse could end his attempt
prematurely but that's not how it
happened
by the time Scott reached his goal
onsens flag was there waiting for him
the Norwegians and their dogs had
comfortably reached the pole five weeks
earlier and we're almost back to their
starting point by the time the English
arrived Scott and his team were
heartbroken they took this photo outside
of Amundsen stent the day they started
their long journey back Scott wrote left
a note to say I had visited the tent
with companions Bauer's photographing
and Wilson sketching we've turned our
back now on the goal of our ambition and
must face our 800 miles of solid
dragging and goodbye to most of the day
dreams
this is where the trouble really begins
it's mid-january in this photo
still the height of the Antarctic summer
told you this chart was coming back
according to their research the team had
about three months left before
temperatures on the Ross Ice Shelf the
last leg of the journey back would drop
to deadly levels that left plenty of
time to make the long trek on foot but
this isn't what happened in 1912 this is
that average line again and these are
the temperatures Scott's party endured
that summer consecutive days of
temperatures around minus 40 degrees
Fahrenheit those conditions that
prolonged exposure are not survivable
the first man died here he collapsed and
soon went comatose following several
Falls on the glacier the next man died
about a month later after crippling
frostbite in his hands and feet began
hurting the team's progress and their
chances of survival nearly unable to
walk he left the tent and sacrificed
himself to a snow storm the last three
including Scott made it here before
getting trapped in their tent by a
blizzard just 11 miles from the supply
depot that would have saved their lives
[Music]
the tent along with the bodies journals
and photographs was found eight months
later by a search team as time went on
Scott's legacy vacillated between
fearless Explorer and bumbling fool who
tried to take ponies into the Antarctic
but the thing is his plan should have
worked
measurements from modern weather
stations along his route show the
predictions he was relying on were
impressively accurate what Scott
couldn't have known is that 1912 was an
anomaly the temperatures his party
suffered through occur roughly once
every 15 years turning an already risky
venture into a hopeless one the photo
they took outside of Amundsen tent was
meant to be a gentlemanly admission of
defeat at the end of a long race but
instead it was the starting line of a
race they didn't see coming a desperate
attempt to escape from the coldest place
on earth
[Music]
darkroom is a new series I'm working on
where each episode tells a story based
around a single photograph here's a
quick look at some upcoming episodes and
you should also check out our new
YouTube membership program the video lab
for monthly fee subscribers get access
to tons of special features I'll be
sharing stuff there that I come across
while making darkroom so if you're
interested head on over to voxcom slash
join and sign up see you there